KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE, JUAN
WILLIAMS, AND JESSE WATERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> THERE HAVE BEEN MEMOS AND
FINGER POINTING AND MUDSLINGING.
NO END NEAR FOR THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION IN CONGRESS.
TIME TO MOVE ON SAYS FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE CONDOLEEZA
RICE.
>> I SPENT TIME IN WASHINGTON.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A HARD JOB AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU ARE DOING
FOR THE COUNTRY, BUT I HOPE YOU
CAN WRAP IT UP.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> LATER ON THE "VIEW" ADAM
DEFENDED THE ON-GOING PROBE.
>> IT'S THE JOB OF THE CONGRESS
TO TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHETHER IT REACHES THE STANDARD
OF REASONABLE DOUBT OR FIND
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
SET OUT THE FACTS ABOUT WHAT THE
RUSSIAN TOLD PAPADOPOULOS AND
TOWER.
>> AND SAID MORE ON FOX NEWS
THIS MORNING.
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE READY TO MOVE ON.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
BUT THE INTEL COMMITTEES NEED TO
FOCUS ON WHAT THE RUSSIANS DID
AND HOW THEY DID IT.
THE FIRST TIME SHAME ON THEM.
THE NEXT TIME SHAME ON US IF
THEY DO IT AGAIN.
TOO LITTLE ATTENTION TO WHAT
THEY DID AND HOW WE WILL DEAL
WITH IT.
>> KIMBERLY, SHE SAID 2 THINGS.
ONE IS THE SCHOOL OF THOUGHT
THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
ON.
THE OTHER THING IS MAKING TOO
MUCH OUT OF WHAT RUSSIA DID BUT
NOT FIGURING OUT HOW TO STOP IF
I FURTHER FUNNY BUSINESS FROM
THEM IN 2018.
>> YOU HAVE TO LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES OF THE PASS.
MAKE IT MORE SURE AND MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T IS INFLUENCE AND CUT
THEM OFF AT THE PASS IN TERMS OF
THEIR INTERFERENCE.
I AGREE WITH WHAT SHE IS SAYING.
IF ANYBODY COULD GIVE GOOD
ADVICE THAT WE SHOULD HEED IT'S
CONDOLEEZA RICE.
>> SHE IS A RUSSIAN EXPERT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS HER AREA OF EXPERTISE
AND ONE OF HER BEGGEST STRENGTH
IS NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT TO UNDERSTAND IT.
TO BE ABLE TO COMBAT AGAINST IT
MORE EFFICIENTLY IN THE FUTURE.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO DO BOTH.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE HOUSE AND
SENATE AND THEIR COMMITTEES WANT
TO DO THEIR CONSITUTIONAL DUTY
AND CHECKS AND BALANCES, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S SUPERSEDED BY
MUELLER.
3 INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON AT THE
SAME TIME.
I THINK THOSE TWO ARE SO
PARTISAN PEOPLE ARE WAITING FOR
MUELLER TO WRAP IT UP.
>> THE HOUSE INVESTIGATION IS
BEYOND PARTISAN.
I DON'T THINK THE SENATE IS THAT
BAD.
I THINK WHAT CONDOLEEZA RICE
SAID IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THAT REFLECTS THE ATTITUDE OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
I HEAR STORIES THIS DAY AND A
DIFFERENT STORY THE NEXT DAY.
I AM NOT SURE WHAT TO MAKE OF
ANY OF IT.
YOU THAT SAID AT TIMES.
IT'S OVERWHELMING.
WHAT PROVES WHAT?
DO WE HAVE ANY BOTTOM LINE HERE?
THE DIFFICULTY IS WHEN PEOPLE --
THERE IS A NEW TERM I HEAR
PEOPLE USE: GASLIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE BEING DELUGED WITH
INFORMATION SOME INTENDED TO
DISTRACT AND CONFUSE THEM.
THEN PEOPLE SAY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THIS
STORY.
IT MAKES MY HEAD HURT.
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
THAT IMPULLS IS THERE.
CONDOLEEZA RICE SAID SHE KNOWS
AND TRUSTS ROBERT MUELLER AND HE
WOULD BE FAIR AND DO A GOOD JOB.
SHE DID NOT CALL FOR THE END OF
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> NO.
>> WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
>> RIGHT.
SHE IS ONE OF THE ONLY ONES FROM
PREVIOUS GOVERNMENTS THAT SAID
WHAT SHE REALLY FEELS.
MOST PEOPLE IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HAVE NOT SAID
ANYTHING, MAYBE THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THINGS THAT COULD COME OUT
LATER.
SHE WAS AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
AND KNOWING THE RUSSIANS AND
WORKED IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
KNOWS OUR EYES SHOULD BE ON THE
IMPORTANT BALL TO PREVENT IT
FROM HAPPENING IT AGAIN.
>> I FEEL LIKE BACK IN THE '90s
OR BEFORE THEN, THERE WERE
HEAVYWEIGHTS IN THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU LOOKED
TO THAT ROSE ABOVE POLITICS.
CONDOLEEZA RICE IS ONE OF THEM.
IT CARRIES A LOT OF WEIGHT WHEN
SHE SAYS THIS.
ADAM SCHIFF CAN GET BOOKED ON
THE "VIEW."
I SHOULD BE BOOKED NEXT.
DID YOU HEAR THE PEOPLE CLAP IN
THE "VIEW" AUDIENCE WHEN SHE
SAID LET'S WRAP THIS UP.
I WAS SURPRISED BY THAT.
BUT WANT SURPRISED.
BECAUSE THE USA TODAY POLL SAID
RUSSIAN IS RANKED DEAD LAST FOR
THE ISSUE OF VOTERS.
IT'S BEEN 9 MONTHS AND COST
MILLION DOLLARS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
I AM NOT SAYING THERE ISN'T.
I BELIEVE IF THERE WAS, IT WOULD
HAVE LEAKED BY NOW.
I WANT TO SEE IT WOUND DOWN AND
COME TO A RIGHTFUL CONCLUSION.
I DON'T TRUST ANYBODY.
I TRUST MYSELF AND THAT'S ABOUT
IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I THINK HE STACKED THE DECK
WITH PEOPLE HE BROUGHT IN.
>> WAIT A SECOND, WHAT ABOUT
YOUR MOM?
>> MY MOM LOVES MUELLER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU DON'T EVEN TRUST YOUR
MOTHER?
>> COME ON!
I WANT TO KNOW EVERYTHING.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE AND COLLUSION AND
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT POTENTIAL
UNMASKING AND POTENTIALLY
PUTTING FRAUD ON THE PRIVATE
FORCE NOT DISCLOSING THAT THE
HILLARY CLINTON FUNDED THE
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
>> ANYTHING ELSE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> LET'S BE QUICK.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO ASK NOW.
>> IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR 9
MONTHS.
THAT'S 2 PORKYPINES IN THEIR
GESTATION PERIOD.
>> WEIRD ANIMAL FACT.
>> IT SHOWS HOW BORED I AM BY
THIS TOPIC.
NUMBER 1, EVERYBODY WANTS THIS
STORY TO MOVE ON EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT IT TO MOVE
ON.
IT'S THE ELECTION LOSERS.
THERE WAS A TERROR ATTACK BLAMED
ON A MOTIVE.
EVERYBODY WAS MOCKED.
THEY SHOWED THE FLAMING CARS AND
MAKING JOKES ABOUT WHY ARE YOU
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME.
MOVE ALONG.
NOTHING HAPPENED THERE.
NOW, THIS IS THEIR BENGHAZI.
THE LONGER THEY CLUTCH IT AND
THE BETTER IT IS FOR RUSSIAN.
RUSSIAN IS THE THIRD WHEEL
TRYING TO BREAK UP A COUPLE,
THAT IS AMERICA.
THEY ARE LIKE THE YOUNG,
ATTRACTIVE MODEL THAT MOVES INTO
YOUR CONDO, RIGHT ACROSS FROM
THE BAY WINDOW.
>> OH MY GOD.
ARE YOU LIKE A PEEPING TOM
PERSON?
>> NOT ANYMORE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I GAVE IT UP.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK.
MY NAME IS GREG BUT I COULD BE
ONE.
>> GOT IT.
>> SEE HOW EXHAUSTING THIS
RUSSIAN STORY IS.
>> THEN THE OTHER THING.
THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR NUNES PUT
OUT ANOTHER LETTER --
>> [LAUGHING].
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> DID YOU WANT ME TO DO IT?
>> NO, NOPE.
YESTERDAY WE HAD THIS WHOLE BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE TALKED ABOUT THEIR LITTLE
SPAT AND IT PLAYS OUT IN PUBLIC.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS DINNER
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
HE SAID THAT HE INSTRUCTED
MICHAEL HOROWITZ THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO INVESTIGATE THE SAME
THING, POSSIBLE FUNNY BUSINESS
WITH THE FISA COURT.
THAT'S ALREADY DONE.
TODAY WE GET ANOTHER LETTER THAT
LAYS OUT THAT NUNES THINKS THERE
COULD BE LAWS BROKEN IN FISA AND
SENDS A LETTER TO JEFF SESSIONS
AND DEMANDS A RESPONSE.
WHAT AM I MISSING?
HE RESPONDED THE DAY BEFORE.
>> JESSE WATERS.
>> OKAY.
HE IS LIGHTING THE FIRE UNDER
JEFF SESSIONS.
HE WANTS TO RAMP UP THE HEAT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THEY CAN ASK DEVIN NUNES
ABOUT HIS ACTIVITIES.
>> THE OPERATIONS GUIDE SAYS YOU
HAVE TO PUT FORTH TO A JUDGE
FACTULE AND VERIFY
FACTULE AND VERIIE
FACTULE AND VERIIED
FACTULE AND VERIIED I
FACTULE AND VERIIED INF
FACTULE AND VERIIED INFOR
FACTULE AND VERIIED INFORMA
FACTULE AND VERIIED INFORMATI
FACTULE AND VERIIED INFORMATION
WHEN YOU WANT A WARRANT TO SPY
ON AMERICANS.
THE DOSSIER FROM HILLARY CLINTON
WAS NEITHER VERIFIED NOR
SUBSTANTIATED.
COMEY ADMITTED THAT.
>> I GET THIS.
>> THAT IS NOT HONEST.
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS ASKING
SESSIONS TO LOOK AT.
>> ONE THING I COULD NOT STAND
IN WASHINGTON WHEN I WORKED ON
CAPITAL ONE AND AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE WHITE HOUSE,
HOW PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES USE
LETTERS TO SOMEBODY ELSE TO GET
ATTENTION.
IT'S SO ANNOYING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP BYPASSES THE
WHOLE PROCESS AND JUST SENDS A
TWEET.
>> I DISAGREE.
I THINK IT'S NICE TO BRING BACK
THE LETTER.
I LOVE HAND WRITING.
FANS WRITE TO ME ABOUT THE SHOW.
I READ EVERY PIECE OF MAIL.
OLDER PEOPLE HAVE BETTER HAND
WRITING.
YOUNG PEOPLE LOOK AT A PEN AND
GET NERVOUS.
>> DO YOU READ THE FAN MAIL FROM
PEOPLE CUTTING OUT LETTERS IN
THE ENVELOPE.
>> I LIKE WHEN THEY WRITE
OUTSIDE ON THE ENVELOPE.
>> THAT'S LIKE JAIL MAIL.
>> YOU GET A LOT OF JAIL MALE.